getting started with spring planting can
be an exciting and rewarding experience
here are some tips to help you begin one
choose the right plants before you start
planting research which plants thrive in
your local climate and soil conditions
consider factors such as sunlight water
availability and temperature to select
the best plants for your garden 2.
prepare your soil good soil is essential
for healthy plants so take the time to
prepare your soil before planting remove
any weeds rocks or debris and add
organic matter such as compost or mulch
to help improve soil health and
fertility three plan your layout
consider the size and shape of your
garden as well as the needs of the
plants you've chosen when planning your
layouts consider grouping plants with
similar water and nutrient needs
together to make maintenance easier four
start small if you're new to gardening
start small with a few plants and
gradually expand as you gain confidence
and experience this will help you avoid
feeling overwhelmed and allow you to
focus on giving each plant the attention
and
5. stay on top of Maintenance regular
maintenance is key to keeping your
plants healthy and thriving this can
include watering fertilizing pruning and
pest control make sure you understand
the specific needs of each plant and
stay on top of Maintenance tasks to help
your garden flourish with these tips in
mind you'll be well on your way to a
successful spring planting season
remember gardening is a learning process
so don't be afraid to experiment and try
new things as you go with patience
persistence and a little bit of know-how
you can create a beautiful and bountiful
Garden that brings you Joy and
satisfaction for years to come